so i want to show you this island check
this out i don't want to fall
okay see that island right there that
island
is owned by larry ellison buys the
entire island 98
of it leaves the beach
doesn't like california now with the
politics decides to move to
his island right outside of maui so i'm
here right now with about 450 of our
sales leaders
um we brought them here their families
you know it's been a crazy last 12
months and everybody
couldn't wait to get away and we
appreciate maui for being able to host
us it was technical
but we made it happen and uh last night
we're up having a cigar with a couple of
guys and they're talking about 50 of us
and uh 1 30 in the morning 1 o'clock in
the morning conversations got
very very deep and you know what we
talked about here's what we talked about
we talked about the concept of people
delaying pressure people delaying
the pressure of performing today it's a
form of
being afraid michael j fox
from uh the movie uh
back to the future biff would probably
call it chicken because you're afraid of
competing today
you're afraid of the pressure today so
you delay the pressure later on
what do i mean by this you said you know
things like oh
you know right now i'm just more you
know focused on
just you know it's not about right now
but but i'm telling you 20 years from
now watch what i'm going to do
unfortunately like life doesn't work
that way it doesn't mean life doesn't
give you second chances
but the longer you delay pressure
the less your spirit knows how to
handle pressure the sooner you
get in the arena and fight
instead of just being a fan or an
audience or
spectator you become someone who goes
into the coliseum
you say i'm scared but i'm kidding
anyways
i don't know if i can fight all these
other guys i have no clue
but i want to get in and get a feel for
it rather than
no no no not right now because it's
embarrassing if i lose
i lose every single day god knows if you
could only see the losses i get
literally last week week before every
day
i have a loss every month a good size
loss and every year
a real loss every year it's been
happening like this for 20 years
it's happened a loss is either business
personal
finance health a ton of things that
could happen
to you every year we're at
uh louisville week prior to this it was
blizzard
snowing i mean i can't even describe to
how bad it looked over there
half the people didn't attend because
they didn't think anybody else was going
to show up
1200 people people were still there
they have kids they had excuses their
pipes blew
up they had all these challenges that
happened they still figured out a way to
get there
why because they want to get in the ring
today now by the way this doesn't mean
i'm not sympathetic about it this
doesn't mean
there's no empathy behind it not at all
had a conversation with one of my
friends yesterday
i said if life 20 years from now
you are at the same position you are
right now would you be okay with it
he said absolutely not i said then you
got to create some urgency because if
the answer is
i don't really care then it's fun i
respect that as well
you know but if it's something where you
say absolutely not i would be so
frustrated if my dreams didn't become a
reality
well then get in the ring it will never
be a convenient that will never be
comfortable it'll never be
the way you wanted it to be that island
wasn't bought because every one of his
days went perfect that island wasn't bad
because
he felt like working every day that
island did wasn't because he didn't get
sued
bullied pushed around challenge
competition that island was bad because
he decided to
go out there and win despite everything
else being
against him and then he gets to say
a smiling it's craziness right so
if you're watching this odds are
this message didn't do anything for 80
percent of it
but there's a high likelihood 20 of you
guys know what i mean that you're
delaying pressure because you're afraid
of getting in the ring today
and if it connects with you this is not
kind of a video you would share with
somebody else like i don't want people
to know
but if it connects with you then go do
something about it i'm not doing this
for viewers i'm doing it because i know
the right people listening to this
are gonna say i am sick and tired of
being chicken
i'm sick and tired of being a sizzia
a pansy
a little baby why are you so scared
you're a grown man you're a grown woman
what are you scared of get in the ring
anyways to enjoy this video i'm going to
share with you i think eight of my
scariest experiences it's a video i did
four or five years ago
for halloween things i experienced some
of them are funny
some of them are scary if you haven't
watched it click over here
with that being said go play scared this
week
meaning whether you're scared or not go
play
put me in coach i'm ready to play go
play let's go play ball
it's not about winning that island it's
about your identity increasing you
playing ball it's exciting man if you go
play ball
anyways looking forward to seeing you
guys kicks on major tail take care
[Music]
everybody